you know I heard that uh Teddy Roosevelt
was a good negotiator and that he was
extremely stubborn
and perhaps the right term for that
would be assertive but he picked his
battles is there some value to
holding strong through principle so I
don't even know if that's probably the
opposite of empathy are there times when
you can just stick be extremely stubborn
to your principles
we do it all the time we just you know
we're just nice about it okay it helps
to be nice you're saying well yes
because I need you to hear me and the
assertive tone of voice
so when when we do our training
typically we do an exercise called 60
seconds so she dies
and I play the bad guy bank robber and I
ask you to be the hostage negotiator
and your job is to give you the four
cons real world constraints
and then you got to try and negotiate me
out of the bank now we're doing this now
the first voice that I always use in
that exercise is this service voice
which is the commanding voice
it's the voice that all police officers
are taught to use in the street
issued loud and clear commands
you know it doesn't it to me I don't
feel like I'm attacking you
I just feel like I'm being direct and
honest and clear
you on the other hand feel attacked
now we're doing this exercise in Austin
a couple of years ago the first
participant has an Apple watch on
he tells us afterwards
that's sitting still
not even answering
when he first gets hit in the face with
the assertive's voice his heart rate
jumped to 170. which is a typical fight
or flight reaction I come at you like
I'm fighting you
your your fight flight mechanisms all
kick into gear which clouds you're
thinking you're automatically Dumber in
the moment
so if I want to make a great long-term
deal with you
highly profitable
I'm agnostic to you being profitable is
it you be profitable that's fine I'm
here to make money for me
making you dumber will always hurt me
me making you feel attacked
will always hurt me so there's never a
value in being in you making me
afraid
there's never a long-term value in it